Stand there.
You're controlling the front
end of a traffic jam, Dean.
So we're going to set
up our traffic jam here.
What I want you to do is when
a car arrives at the back,
just pull off the
car at the front.
Pull it along the road.
OK, so first car coming in.
Second car.
Carry on.
What you can see is the
traffic jam moves backwards
along the road.
That's it.
OK, thanks very much, Dean.
[APPLAUSE]
So traffic jams move
backwards along the road.
Now, we actually have some
real traffic data here
taken from a section of the M25.
Now, here we have the section
between junction 10, junction
15.
Cars flow in this
direction along the road.
And this is a snapshot
of the traffic.
Now, the dark regions
are where the traffic
is moving very slowly.
So you can think of
it as a traffic jam.
And the light regions
are where the traffic
is moving reasonably quickly.
So there's no traffic jam there.
And this was taken at 8
o'clock in the morning.
Now, as time moves
on, of course,
we just saw, traffic
jams move on.
And so if I slide
this along, you
can actually see let's
just take one traffic jam.
It's black in the centre here.
You can actually see it move
backwards along the road.
Now, of course,
no one driver has
knowledge of what's
happening on the whole road.
But if we look at
the pattern that's
formed along the
road for all time,
we begin to see something
that does indeed
resemble some kind
of pattern, not
completely dissimilar from
the patterns, the lines we're
getting on these mixed grains
that are rotating around there.
And this pattern isn't
completely regular.
But it isn't
completely irregular.
If it was disordered, then
the black and the white
would be smeared out
all over the place.
They'd just be
completely disorganised.
But we can see some
kind of ordering there.
And it's understanding
these kind
of patterns and the realisation
that the patterns that
occur in things like
traffic are very
similar to the
patterns that occur
in, for example, in sand and
in many other things in nature.
That's giving scientists
an understanding
about what happens in
time in these systems.
And that's the key,
then, to getting
some level of predictability
about the future.